I'm here at beautiful I don't know where
beats the hell out of me
but my guest tonight is a New York Daily
News columnist and CNN contributor her
new show SE Cupp unfiltered premieres
July 17th on HLN
please welcome SE Cupp yeah now you're a
Republican and Jeb Bush and Marco Rubio
both criticized me this week should more
Republicans be standing up to me or
should they shut up
you know I'd love it if more Republicans
and conservatives took a stand against
the things they believed in not less
than you know 200 days ago it's been
pretty disappointing to see how the
party has unified not around the
principles but around having an R in the
White House there's no wonderful no my
name is T it's t not R my mistake what
do you think it's because they care
about maintaining control in a party
system that's so partisan that it
actually counteracts the ability for
people to govern I think there's they're
certainly interested in keeping control
and keeping a majority the problem is
what have they really been able to do
with this majority not a whole lot you'd
think that having nearly every lever of
power in Washington you'd be able to get
I don't know health care passed you only
had seven years to work on it we totally
did it we did it didn't you see I went
in the Rose Garden and I said my
catchphrase which are you normally only
say on the television show I'm the
president can you believe it you wrote
an article called
our endless stream of scandal is that
did you watch all of scandal on Netflix
to philosophize yeah so how do we parse
all the messes that I'm involved in yeah
well there's a lot and there's a lot of
legitimate controversies and scandals
that we as a press and we as a public
and and we as a legislature should be
looking at very seriously and we are but
there's also some distract
ding nonce candles like you swatting
your wife's hand away on a on a foreign
trip I was not a dory
I was waving at her but really low okay
I think when media outlets serious and
credible media outlets create an
equivalency between that non story and
and real issues that are troubling I
still wonder why people hate the media
and feel like they can't trust us fake
news right fake news isn't it true that
that problem that generally people have
at a level that's almost underneath
their consciousness of the fact that
mainstream media at this point is a
scandal to scandal breaking news collage
has created a problem in which real
stories get covered up by exactly what
you're saying this type of scandal and
then I can come in label it fake news
and rob us of a real dialogue about the
responsibilities of the Fourth Estate
yeah look the big new thing is that is a
problem and as you know a member of the
media I find that to be really really
unfair however if you're a news consumer
it's hard to tell the difference between
not news and fake news and and I I'm
concerned that when media outlets focus
on the not news then the newest viewer
will have a very difficult time telling
the difference
you're a very likeable conservative and
I'm a very unlikable conservative also
not a conservative excuse me I'm so
conservative si thinks that what you
know that's really great why am I not a
conservative I don't think you have any
undergirding conservative I bought
undergirding president that's me
badged tight bad word choice you know as
you've said you know you you're not
married to a political party this is how
you got elected I think you wore the
Republican Party like a rented tuxedo to
get elected and and it works thank you
if it's it and I wish I wish you'd be a
little less insecure you one stop
you know obsessing about how or who
didn't vote for you enough people liked
you to make you president so just do the
job
Everman three million people voted
illegally and if hillary hadn't won any
of the votes I would have gotten all of
them you know that that's the way it
works right I have one lives question
what are three places where liberals and
conservatives can see eye-to-eye with
each other if not agree but at least
work towards understanding huh today
like these liberals and conservatives
yeah or jeez it seems like it seems
difficult honestly because we are so
tribal and we are so encamped in our in
our political ideologies and the idea
that we can come together on causes
seems almost nostalgic and and and
that's that's very disappointing but I
have faith that there are very good
people on both sides of the aisle I know
some of them in the house and in the
Senate who if they can emerge out of
this morass at some point will be able
to to work together on on some of those
those causes that that used to unite
both of our parties
not long ago I have an idea of what's
going to unite both parties my
impeachment I speak up everybody
[Music]
[Applause]